so hi everyone my name is Sonia I leave
the personalization team without brains
or combinations board and today I'm
going to talk to you about our
recommender system then specifically two
layers two different layers of our
recommender system so the first layer
might be our offline there are offline
modeling LAN which works on top of spark
and the second one will be the serving
sizes serving there which is running on
top elasticsearch so really quick
introduction on out brain many of you
probably heard of the company basically
our brain focuses on discovery what we
do is help readers to discover content
that is interesting and relevant to them
and this is how it looks like so if you
are reading an article let's say on CNN
you're reading a story you got to the
bottom of the story and you're seeing
your widget and the widget has two types
of recommendations first type we're
calling them organic accommodations so
these are basically links that lead you
to other articles within CNN the second
type are the promoted stories so these
are links that are taking you outside of
sin and outside of the current publisher
and this could be this could be leading
into site if you know other publishers
to just want to draw audience to to
their sites or you can lead you to
marketers or brand that have content on
a new product that they that they are
that they're marketing okay so we have
offices in 14 locations many web sites
and apps display our recommendations and
these are the numbers which you know
they are important for us in terms of
you know machine learning engineers so
we we are serving 275 billion
a month and we're reaching about 1
billion users and we'll get back to
those numbers
once we talk public literature ok so so
before we dive in in into the system
itself let's talk about our Xenia what
kind of data were using and first first
and foremost we are we want to know our
users we want to get to know the users
so that we can recommend relevant
content to these users and essentially
the way we know this user is users is by
looking at what articles they're reading
what content they are consuming ok so
this means that we need to fully
understand what's happening in this
within this content so basically it all
starts with their MLP engine ok what
that means is that we're taking articles
and these are you know we're getting
documents from all the articles where
our widget is being displayed ok this is
the first type of documents that we're
analyzing and the second type are all of
the articles which are our potential
recommendations ok we need to understand
both of these types of content so what
we're doing is we're crawling them and
applying it'll be techniques to extract
features and our features we have
different levels of granularity of
semantic features so as you can see
these are three examples of features
that we are using we have you know more
abstract layer of categories so it's
about 100 categories this is like the
higher level classification that we're
doing then we have topics which are a
bit more specific and we also have
specific very specific entities so these
are you know specific people or specific
organizations so these are the kind of
features were extracting so here you can
see an example article and effective
feedback theory and we have it was
classified to entertainment television
something more specific is a sitcom and
you know specific entities you know we
have see
yes my golly so you can recognize those
okay so so we have information on each
and every one of our articles now what
are we doing with that we are now we're
getting a user we have the patterns of
what this user has been reading in the
past and what we're basically doing is
aggregating are you getting all this
information into one user profile so you
can see it as in a sense this user
profile is represented in the same
feature space as our each one of our
articles right so each user profile has
a category has a topic has a list of
categories a list of topics of this term
entities and so forth so here's an
example of user in the system that
happened to read a lot about television
and infesting and music so this is the
aggregated profile and if you would have
looked at my profile
last spring this is what you would have
seen so I don't know if you recognize
these entities in categories how many of
you haven't watched the Royal Wedding or
are ashamed to admit they had haven't
what or ashamed to admit ok so ok ok so
I'm speaking about being chained to
admit we're reading consuming certain
content or watching certain youtubes
this is something about share with you
this is a research two of our
researchers have conducted several years
ago rahmatullah in the oiseau song and
what they wanted to check is whether
there is any gap between the things that
we read about first of the things that
we share and they kind of wanted to
evaluate what is that know what what is
the value of the data our brain has
versus you know your
book friends or social media so they
analyzed all the shares they took a lot
of pages and they took about Facebook
shares and what they came up with is
these results so basically you have two
types of topics you have topics that we
tend to read about but we don't usually
share and we have topics that we tend to
share but we kind of rarely read about
and you can guess which one is which so
so this is this is to emphasize the
value of the data that we have based on
you know this very implicit interests of
the users okay so we've talked about the
data that's talked about their models we
we basically have two types of
predictive models one is content-based
models it means that we are representing
so we talked about the user we had we
have we have a profile we have it the
interests of the user and this kind of
models they tend to recommend content
which is semantically similar to what
our users are interested in okay so if I
am interested in music or in technology
and travel this kind of algorithms will
probably recommend things related to
those topics and these are the content
based models and the other titles
predictive models are collaborative
models you all familiar with probably
choice women with at least one to you
know hundreds and thighstr
that generate is kind of models but
essentially as we all know this is a the
basic concept of this type of models is
that you know if my taste matches
someone else's stage probably the things
that they were like will interest me as
well and we are using three types of
algorithms for these matches of
citations transition machines and
embeddings right isn't it clear okay
and just to formulate so for dive into
the infrastructure roles that I just to
formulate if I'm machinery challenge so
what we have is basically on whether we
have the the features the feature
vectors in this consists
to type features we have the user and we
have the context in the current by
context I mean what is the exact article
the user is currently reading it's very
important to the prediction it could be
what platform of the user is using
whether it's mobile or desktop and what
time is it what day of the week it is so
this is the context right and we have
the user interests these are the
features and on the labeling side we
have all the recommendations that we
served in the past and whether there was
a clicker so it's a binary prediction
problem okay so okay so the question is
how the texts are labeled and we have an
in-house and OPM term that actually
extracts all these features every team
which is that's okay so let's talk about
alpha and data processing so said that
I'm going to cover two layers the offer
layer and the serving flavor that's
always start with you offering one way
so a couple months ago I bought into
this YouTube and it's by discount fumble
and I recommended one by the way so he
was talking about machine learning
technical debt and and what he was
saying is that essentially machine
learning systems are very complex in
terms of engineering not only you know
they'll go to think about and you know
often they're even more complex with you
know other back-end systems and they are
there are certain concepts that we need
to that we need to to make sure that are
happening so that our systems are lost
and this is not not not always the case
and I wanted to show you two slides that
I really like from here there are kind
of motivation for what we're doing so
this is the first way the first way is
you have the cool part of machine
learning
this is the part where you actually
write the code of the algorithm and you
do have a parameter tuning and you do
cost function and you you know changing
the algorithm that you download it from
somewhere and and this is the really fun
stuff that we all like doing but this is
a very small part of what's happening
okay right this is a very small square
of what's going on but actually we have
the rest of machine learning here and
and the rest of machine learning is all
the engineering tool stuff around it all
these components which are pretty boring
but they are necessary have data
collection feature instruction
configuration monitoring deployment and
so forth and it turns out that about 90%
of the time of you know machine learning
engineers data scientist is actually
around these parts are not the core part
of you know improving theorem proving my
algorithm and what our machine learning
framework it attempts to do is to reduce
the cost of these parts ok so as you'll
see many so just to give you a few
examples of why why this is take you
know any percent of our time so what
they set out and what we what we have
are really tough tasks so let's talk
about data collection right data
preparation so I guess most of you can
relate to those things right first we
have multiple data stores ok we are
going to have highways equal Cassandra
secondly we have everything in different
tables because we have different types
of events and those events are going
through different flows and are written
to different places so in our case we
have we have recommendations then we
have clicks we have user profiles each
one of these type of
has written clear differences and we
need to somehow I believe them
we have logic that we need to apply
usually to do paint styling stuff that
everyone needs but everyone needs to
implement and all this have is you know
happens in scale so this means that you
know it takes a lot of times where I'm
this great so the complexity is twofold
first we need to really work hard to
implement those stuff and secondly when
we already implement them it takes our
time to run just to generate the single
dataset and we want we want to reduce
this cost okay and another example so
this was data collection I think I
convinced you that it's pretty complex
and time-consuming evaluation metrics so
this is a snapshot of our amount of the
dance evaluations were you know
summarize the evaluation metrics for for
what we're doing and you know these
these are we have like more than 15 of
those you know you have stuff which are
classical machine learning you know and
we'll see and you see you have stuff
which elevated to rank in our case like
we're ranking like camera and we have
stuff related to business where we take
into account the monetization of what
we're getting
so there are large metrics and
implementing though this is is it's
constant okay so so so this is why we
you know came to the conclusion that we
need to develop some framework and
basically we have to we have two goals
in mind the first was what a performer
agile research okay we wanna focus on
modeling and enabling quick POC and the
second one is that we want to have a
robust product ization mechanism and and
and this is so when you want to have it
in in to say you know in two different
dimensions what is that you want to be
able to refresh our models automatically
women you know simplify the way we
deploy models and secondly we want to
make this process safe and I will talk
about it in a second so how do you make
sure that you know your production
viruses are corrupted okay so we chose
to a spark fastest distributor all our
information is on the cross there's
actually a smoker
we have sparked the top of that and then
we have this applicational layer where
we implemented on the framework that
machine variable and this framework is
basically composed out of five
components so none of these are
surprising but the thing is that they
are decoupled that's that's the
important thing
and so we have data collection feature
engineering model training our final
affiliation and model deployment
component them and in the way it serves
on some terms of the two goals that
we've defined is that so agile research
it it enables us to get models in very
quickly the reason is that essentially
what we need to reemployment whenever we
introduce a new motto is only two
components and usually totally the third
one it's only the model training we
don't even need to touch the feature
extraction and everything else is out of
the box and obviously as you can see you
know data collection and outside
information are things which are
independent of your model right
so when and you you know I machine
learning the engineer wants to implement
a new model though the way to do it is
basically implement two functions and
all the rest is is ready for you know
for running the job so we have their
columns basically it means that we're so
I think they don't want to use it we
have the actual logic of the algorithm
that we are implemented and in the the
next stage you know after implementing
these parts are just you know running
the SPARC job getting the data
collections for free daily getting the
affiliations for free
that's okay
so I second goal was the deployment part
so this is why this fifth component is
for and basically well wanted to do is
use the same basically use the same
framework to both run it in research and
a doc and boast relative production okay
so we have an in-house scheduler it just
basically runs the same code but on the
scheduled manner regardless of what you
know model you might be using you do
want to refresh the other part of the
data right whether it's every five
minutes or every you know every two
weeks but it's something that you want
to have that semantically done for you
so we have the scheduler and it actually
runs the same code that we were using in
research and this last part the model
deployment not only you know places the
models in production but it also takes
the output of the offer and evaluation
our component and sees whether this
model is good enough whether this model
you know doesn't know anything
it still you know brings the lips that
we expect it to bring before it has been
deployed and you know potentially harms
our production environment kay questions
before moves to the serving there
exactly so the money's running the
question was about monitoring the models
so there are two two checkpoints first
is before we want to apply the new model
we want to check it on off-site data and
make sure that it's you know it's
comparable with our previous results and
that you know it brings down the metrics
are you know high enough value and the
second thing you know after it is
deployment we have monitoring obviously
on the online system and how it actually
performs because not you probably know
that you know off by metrics are really
nice but they don't know what's predict
what's happening online so it's really
important to have this both you know
safeguard layers so moving on to the sir
okay so remember the number is from the
second slide that I've showed you with
the throughput so if you do this quick
calculation per month this is per second
so this is the throughput we have 35
arcane requests per second that we need
to to handle quick recommendation
requests and we need to meet a very
strict latency requirement which is 30
milliseconds and the reason is that you
know when when someone opens some
article on CNN they expect to see our
recommendations right away so we need to
admit this acquirement and in the third
challenge that we have is that our
inventory is very you know as large we
have several millions of potential
recommendations for which we need to
choose the best ones so this is a pretty
challenging you know engineering task of
how to tackle it and what we did is we
turned it to a different domain and in a
sense in this different domain many of
these problems aren't already solved and
I'll show you how how we how we done the
reduction between the two so so we're
using search technologies were using
elastic search and just you know a brief
overview of why you know distributed
search engines are good for what we're
trying to do so first of all main you
know the main thing that search engines
know how to do is getting a query and
ranking documents as in terms of their
relevance to this grade right this is
like though many things are changing can
do in terms of the distributed part of
search engines they are distributed in
two kinds of inter types of dimensions
so one is that we are able to scale in
terms of inventory size and we're just
adding those to elasticsearch not
getting into visible powers to search
works but it's basically increasing your
roster then you're able to handle a
larger inventory this is one thing and
the second thing is that you know as
your throughput you know what was higher
you can again
send your custard you just add more
machines and it's capable okay so this
these are the advantages and these are
the key points that made us turn to this
direction so just a quick quick overview
of what makes search engine efficient
probably those of you who had some you
know connection to search know those
this to spice with kind of quarry but
essentially what makes what makes them
efficient is that you know when we index
some document into into a search engine
they created inverted index they're not
indexes and the infrared change and
what's happening is that we have a
record parent chart and for each record
the keys the tournament the values are
its documents where the key appears and
then when we're getting into our query
then it's very simple and efficient to
just locate all the records that are
very relevant to this query and then
search engine does two things very
quickly eliminate filters out with stuff
that are don't contain the terms at all
so this is like the majority of the
imagery just goes away and among the
ones that I don't know the right it
applies a heuristic or the scoring you
know what is more relevant what is less
relevant and you know it's usually has
to do with stuff like the number of
times a term the beauties document how
popular is this term so they're kind of
kind some earlier istic that are being
used okay so this is like the classical
search engine now in our case we are
doing when we're reducing our problem to
a search problem and we're doing it in
the following way so we're indexing our
documents we're indexing all our
inventory into elasticsearch but instead
of indexing the terms instead of
choosing that with words we are indexing
the features okay
so these are at the terms that we're
using we're converting words into two
we're representing all our documents
with feature
so if you look at the very good index
you would see as keys you would see the
semantic features that I talked about
before like that we have you know the
entities the the categories the topics
you will see those here and then this
second reduction that we're doing is on
the query side so what's happening on
the query side is that we're getting a
user and we're representing this user
through profile right through the
through the features of this profile now
if you remember the way we actually
built the profile is making sure that it
is the same feature space where we're
presenting them within this you know
it's the same set of categories is the
same set of set of topics the same set
of entities okay so they are speaking
the same language
just as no queries and documents and you
know and then search engine just
retrieves the monster influence for us
now what I've just described is a very
very simple you know ranking scenario
and it is it correlates with the content
based models that I that I mentioned
before but what we usually use in your
more complicated models right that's
what we have this awful model framework
for described before so so recently
budding zones and impressions and these
are stuff that cannot be really
represented within within the simple
heuristic of a search engine so the way
we actually incorporate this models into
the serving snack just by using elastic
search plug-ins so I don't know if you
whoever knows about stick starts with a
problem where where it's a feature
but when Fighting's enable you to do is
to write your own scoring function
basically okay so you write your own
scoring function in native Java you
deploy this across your cluster you
instruct elasticsearch to use that one
instead of
and you can do whatever you want there
basically of course you are limited in
terms of efficiency you need to be very
efficient in your code because this code
will be run for each and every one of
potential documents that is going to
consider right for your query so there
is a challenge of writing this and in an
efficient manner but it doesn't able us
to incorporate you know any models that
could be anyone that we weren't into
into this stack you know faster search
okay so this is last five key takeaways
and takeaway number one do invest in
your machine learning high five
it will make your research you know more
agile and as you've seen that as you
know before you know we have a lot of
overhead in terms of all the components
that we're using if we want to reduce
that so for that do you invest time in
in the pipeline
I am a periodic model deployment this is
something of you know will help you to
be more agile in deploying new models
have control mechanisms not to ruin your
production and if possible be creative
in terms of looking for solution in
different domains just like we did in
terms of the reduction from recommender
systems to search ok that's it thank you
questions with co-star problem so yeah
this is a huge topic in one sentence
might yeah there
so it depends I mean on the inventory
side we have information which is not
dependent on whether we actually served
or tried this recommendation before
because we have an engine that actually
tells us what this article is about so
this really helps us to understand that
even before we've tried it out on the
user level and this is the first time
we're seeing a user we will probably
mostly use its context
Who am I you don't have any information
about what they like or don't like so we
will focus on what they are seeing right
now which is a very strong signal
obviously thank you
[Applause]